hello everyone and welcome to round 8 of
the 2018 ranked HS classic now if you're
confused about the title of the video
it's it's because during the live
coverage
Peter Lake who was actually telling some
cool stories about about Bobby Fischer
so if you're interested in hearing those
if you like Bobby Fischer do check it
out you can find the the recording of
the entire round 8 on chess 24th YouTube
channel so you know feel free to check
it out you can just rewind to the
stories if you don't want to watch the
entire thing but as there are some very
interesting stories I'm sure you will
enjoy hearing them very much so
about this game Fabiano Caruana vs. 11
ireland so it's a very important round
for both of them Fabiano is still in the
lead so half a point ahead of Khasan and
Nikita be Cuba and a full point ahead of
Levin Aragon so if Aragon wins this game
he will be tied with Fabiana Caruana and
not in first place as I'm sure maybe we
took over cross and can win their games
but can definitely become a contender
for for first place so a very important
game for both of them and it's it's very
interesting what openings they decide to
go for especially what Ireland decides
to go for and you know it perhaps raises
some questions and before we check out
the game I do
we do have some very interesting photos
from round 8 so let's just dive straight
into them here we have a nice photo of
Maxime beshear allograph arriving at at
round 8 here we have Magnus Carlsen
arriving with Peter Nielson Hine his his
coaching trainer it's a bit blurry but
you know that's because they're walking
here we have an excellent photo of Leven
onion munching at what appears to be a
piece of bread maybe it could be a cake
but I don't think he would be having
cake before before a game with with
Fabiano so here we have an excellent
photo of the Frenchman here is the
deadly stare of Maxime Bashar allograft
al would definitely approve of this and
here we have what what are you looking
at for stare bye
world champion magnus carlsen and here
we have two two photos of today's game
here is a nice close-up of LaVon Aragon
and a nice close-up of Fabi so I do hope
you enjoyed those let's check out the
game so like I said a very important
game for both of them so it's very
interesting what they decided to play E
4 E 5 Knight to f3 knight c6 and Bishop
to b5 it's okay the rule opus seems to
be a standard now at every tournament
Knight to f6 the Berlin defense we have
castles Knight captures on e4 at the Rio
gambit rook to e1 Knight to d6 attacking
the bishop on b5 and now Knight captures
on e5 Bishop to e7 and allowing any
discoveries and now Bishop back to f1
Knight captures rook captures and Aragon
castles d4 Bishop to f6 attacking the
rook rook to e2 a rook 3-1 sorry we have
nice to f5 and now d5 rook to e8
offering a trade of rooks Bishop to d3
rook captures Queen captures and now
Queen to e7 by orange and offering a
trade of Queens
so Queen captures on e7 Knight captures
on e7 and here is a very interesting
position basically all the all of the
moves up until this point were played
instantaneously and this movie as well
by Fabiano so here although White has a
couple of options you could go c4 maybe
defend this pawn you could go 3/4 to
defend it but Fabi goes for the most
principled move d6 and it is the engines
top recommendation so definitely a
prepared line by Fabi the idea is you
don't want you don't want to protect the
pawn on d5 by playing d6 you you force
black to capture it and to mess up his
own pawn structure
so pawn captures and now Knight to a3
this night is coming either to be 5 or
c4 and from there it will be it will be
a very strong piece black will not be
able to protect both of his double
points and nor does black want to do so
because you can do have to develop this
light square bishop to develop the rook
and
these pawns are kinda in the way it'd be
terrible for black if white could create
some sort of a blockade you know maybe
maybe put a knight here and then and
then protect it so black really would be
terrible there so d5 immediately nice
the b5 and now d6 it would seem these
six to start developing your pieces you
have to give the pawn back it would be a
pretty terrible idea to go something
like a six with the idea that after
night the c7 you can play rook to b8 and
you keep all of the pawns the d5 point
is protected but then white has this
Bishop to f4 and then this rook will be
a target for many discoveries so black
will not have a lot of fun here so after
Knight b5 b6 giving back the pawn Knight
captures and now Knight to c6 Bishop to
f4 and now Bishop to e6 developing
developing the bishop and not not
allowing white exchange bishop for a
knife for a bishop
so here Knight captures on b7 also an
idea could be to play Bishop captures on
b2 but then you have rook to be one
Bishop to d4 and after Knight captures
rook captures and rook captures you
don't really gain anything here so no
reason to capture the b2 point so after
Bishop to f4 instead Bishop to e6
like we said nightcap for somebody 7
nice to b4 and here Knight to c5 and
interesting but a bad move would be a 3
because now you get Bishop capture some
b2 attacking the rook rook to be one now
cap Knight capture some d3 defending the
bishop and also the attacking the bishop
on f4 and huh now there's also a problem
of the a 3 point actually being under
attack so you don't really you don't
really want to capture anything if you
capture the night then you'll lose the a
3 point if you capture there's really
nothing to capture here so white would
have to go Bishop to d6 still leave all
of these pieces attacked and after black
grabs the pawn here then you would have
rook captures and after
Knight to d1 it would actually be a
great position for black as black would
be up up up upon so after night the B
fortnight the c5 now we have Bishop
capture some b2 rook to b1 and now
Knight capture son b3 c capture some d3
and now Bishop to d4 attacking the
knight on c5 offering White's to capture
the bishop on e6 but that was only that
will only improve black's pawn structure
so no reason in doing that Bishop to e3
offering a trade of bishops but we have
Bishop captures on c5 Bishop captures
and now this this tricky d4 move and
basically now it's a it's a rook and
opposite called bishop same game with
the with the almost exact same pawn
structure and there is really nothing to
do here
so Bishop captures on a 7 one last one
let's try but it's the best move
definitely of course you can't capture
because this leads the checkmate
so instead after Bishop to a7 butter to
a to attacking the rook and now rook to
b8 this comes with check rook captures
Bishop captures and now there's to be
one Bishop a7 Bishop a2 and a repetition
of moves after Bishop to v8 the the
players agree to a draw but if you look
at this a very nice completely
symmetrical structure okay it'd be
better if the pawns were up for one
square but you know very nice so III
don't think this I don't think they're
ever not ever but in this tournament I
don't think there was a game a play that
was this this equal this is like the
embodiment of equality this is what I
mean the game was completely equal from
move one until until the end so I mean
it's a great preparation by by Fabiano
he's really really showing some you know
amazing chess skills but it's a it's a
weird move by eleven because he really
had to win this game to maybe try and
win the tournament why you know what
could be the reason that he decided not
to do so it could be his poor
performance in the candidates tournament
he doesn't want to do anything crazy and
I just want to wants to get his rating
back maybe get back into the
world's top ten and you're Mia maybe he
just wants to play a nice tournament and
then start going for winning tournaments
again as he is the defending champion of
last year's ranking chess classic so
it's it's kind of strange that he
decided not not to play for winning this
game even though yeah okay to have a
black against Fabiano but xi always
always plays for the win and always
tries to create something so okay maybe
it's a weird weird choice of openings
but although although with peers to be a
draw line and in the boring opening for
me on that level on a 2800 and Beyond
level you know there could actually be
tons of chances here but again I did
prepare the final standings not the
finals standings after round eight so
here they are Carwin are still in first
place with five and a half points
Carlson and Vic you go only half a point
behind then we have maxime beaugeois
grab a lemon our noon with four and a
half blue bomb with for an ID each with
three Anand also with three - also with
three and then guru Meyer in last place
with two and a half points so a lot of a
lot of interesting games have been
played so far and it seems that Gege -
and the Viswanathan Anand are still
without a win in this tournament
maybe I've missed someone but I don't
think so yeah three of them are still
without are without wins so they will
have round nine still to play and maybe
maybe achieve a victory and I did
prepare the pairings of the last round
here we have - versus night each 11
Origen vs. blue bomba Cuba versus Kawana
Island versus Carlson and Maxine Bashir
Alegre versus Gehrig Meier so a lot of
things can happen in in the final round
and you know it's interesting that
Caruana if he wants to win the
tournament he has he has to play one
more excellent game against the veto go
who is in second place and we to go has
the white pieces and Carlsen if he wants
to win the tournament you know he has to
do something again
- shhhhh wanna turn around with the
black pieces definitely not the simplest
of tasks so yeah pretty much anything
can happen here even I believe in some
weird way in some yeah okay since yeah a
lot of calculation here but I think a
lot of people can still win this
tournament I'm not sure I didn't
calculate it but maybe maybe even of a
holograph and Aronian both still have
chances so yeah those were the standings
and the pairings of the last round I do
hope you enjoyed the photos I do hope
you enjoyed the game I would like to
thank David Turnbull freewill and Dave
and Jonathan Illinois for a contribution
to my channel thank you a lot - really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos Syria thank you
all for watching and I will see you soon
with probably at least one more game
from the final round of the Greg HS
classic thank you all and I will see you
soon